ladies and gentlemen may I present
producer Anthony Russo and director Sam
Hargrave what's funny is it was a year
ago basically I think this month that we
did gray man here on the stage this
theater uh so I guess this is a yearly
thing now yeah I guess so I was having
strong flashbacks coming in because I
was Hallowed Ground I'm honored to be
here
yeah this theater is a special place
also this theater if you guys just got
here but um I was here for the testing
of the movie it was so loud in here was
it loud when you guys were watching
well what I wouldn't know was it loud
from you all reacting to the movie
sounds like it sounds like a good crowd
a ton of questions for you guys so the
first extraction was one of the biggest
hits in Netflix history for original
movies uh for both of you
for both of you talk a little bit about
what that means to you especially with
it being like your first feature well
for me it's a dream come true as a
director as an artist to see an audience
respond that positively to your work to
two years of your life up on the screen
is is amazing it's what the fuel for the
Fire gets you up in the morning but we
had no idea that it was going to be so
well received so thank you all fans of
the first movie for
um responding so positively and by doing
so
creating the impetus for this movie
yeah look at we knew we knew it was a
special movie uh when after Sam had gone
through the process and we had a
finished film
um but yeah you never know what what the
audience reaction is going to be and I
do think that like I love that my
favorite part of the process is when
movies start to become a dialogue with
the audience and I feel like we really
experienced that with the first
extraction in terms of the the the way
the movie was received the way audiences
responded to the movie I think really
helped him to form the creative life of
the franchise moving forward you know
which is great how quickly was it after
that first weekend when it did crazy
numbers that Netflix called you and said
hey let's talk about a sequel or was it
before the first one came out they were
already saying I think we're going to
want a sequel to this I mean my memory
which is fallible was as we were
shooting we the the script that I signed
on for Tyler's story was finished at the
end of it he didn't he didn't survive in
it but it was early test screenings
internally with Netflix and agbo where
we started to say you know we might have
something here and then once we had an
audience test screen again early on we
we decided to let's go back and make
sure that we have a way out meaning or a
way into a sequel should audiences
respond as the test audiences did and so
we had that you know kind of
artistically ambiguous ending which
would allow should people not respond
positively
um that we could have you know a
complete story or if they did as the
audiences did we could move on to the
second one but it was pretty quick once
audiences responded and they said there
was what 99 million views in 30 days or
something
thank you
that yeah they were like well what's the
second one
of the things that I remember this uh
because Joe I could never Joe Joe your
brother I could never pin him down on a
sequel because at times he was talking
about it being a prequel or a sequel and
so talk a little bit how much how many
of you guys remember that where like
they were talking about it could be a
prequel or a sequel so was it always
going to be a sequel or was there
actually any sort of chance that it
would have been a prequel
well here's the thing you know you want
to keep your options open for where you
take a story right and what the only
what the thing you know is what you've
either written or shot or edited or
presented to an audience that's until
you presented something to an audience
it's all fluid it remains constantly
fluid so and you're always thinking our
process is to always be thinking about
options and possibilities and different
ways we can go to surprise ourselves and
therefore hopefully surprise audiences
so there's always possibilities in the
air about where something can go or what
it can be including you know there's
even a way that Tyler rake died at the
end of the first movie yet there could
be another extraction you know with
another character right they're all
possibilities so that that was all in
the air I think the reason why we went
in the direction of what Sam was just
describing in terms of figuring out how
Tyler could possibly go on is because
people were responding so strongly not
just to the movie but specifically to
Chris Hemsworth's performance as that
character and once we realized how
special that character was that started
to um sort of guide us yeah we said
bring him back
CPR
so listen let's let's uh the action set
pieces in this movie and in the first
movie are fantastic and
so I'm so thank you I'm so curious talk
a little bit about how it actually gets
figured out in terms of the like are you
coming up with the idea of a prison
break and then we're writing around that
or are you coming up like how do these
action set pieces and the script uh get
developed together so it's one it all
you know what I mean like how talk a
little bit about that designing process
well I know Anthony can probably speak
much more closely to Joe's process but
as I understand it I mean the first
inkling I heard of the second movie once
we decided we were moving forward was
Joe said you know I have a really cool
idea I think Tyler Rick should extract
somebody I don't know who it is but from
a prison
all in a Warner and I first I heard of
it and I was like that's a really cool
idea
and then what else do we gonna do
and you know the movie grew from there
and in Joe's process as he kind of works
through again I think Anthony could
probably speak more closely to that but
as I understand it he's charting the
course of the action set pieces so that
as a production you can start prepping
ahead of time while you fill in kind of
the details of the story and he's really
fast at that and the stuff happens
really quickly and it's very distinct
and strong that's a strong suit of his
in my opinion so we had very quickly
kind of an outline of really fun A
Journey For The Character locations wise
and kind of set pieces and we would
discuss what would be the most fun thing
to do there
uh but then the life started to come in
and the bones started to be filled out
with the meat of the story as we were
progressing
that's how I remember it
I love how you qualify that that's how I
remember because I'm constantly doing
that myself as well I have no idea if
it's accurate or not
um but uh I will say this it was
um
a lot of that idea for the Wonder moving
forward in extraction two was certainly
goes back to the experience of it in the
original extraction and you're sort of
vision for that shot and how it could be
what it could be how to execute it it
was you know anytime you try a winner in
filmmaking you know it's a bit of a
scary thing and it's a commitment
because that shot no matter how long it
is
it has to be as compelling and
interesting and sort of Relentless and
sort of uh textured as any Montage of
shots you could put together because
when you play out the winner you're like
if I want to put scissors here and cut
this up for any reason then it shouldn't
be a Warner so it's there's a really
high threshold for a shot like that to
work and Sam was so focused on that in
the original film that that shot and he
executed it so well that it became and
it surprised all of us and then surprise
that it works so well ultimately
everybody was a little anxious about it
so I think that was certainly the
inspiration what you were able to do
with that creatively was certainly the
inspiration for expanding upon that idea
I could be wrong about this but with
extraction 2 originally I read that it
was going to be filming in Australia and
then you moved it so what was the film
different when it was going to be in
Australia or what what happened that is
correct we originally decided to shoot
in Australia for many reasons one of
which was at the time it was covered
free this was 2021 and there was not a
single case on the island
so we were like great choice no masks
just so happens that during our
quarantine
the outbreak started
and so when when they there wasn't us
You Talk Amongst yourselves we didn't
bring Goku to Australia
somebody else did
that's how I remember it
you're not going to say who
no I'm not naming names
however it happened
kovid kind of spread very quickly we
tried to persevere as long as we could
we actually got to within seven or eight
weeks before starting to film when we
had to pull the plug and leave so we had
spent I think 16 weeks prepping in
Australia we had stages full of built
sets we had locations set we had cast in
roles that we had to recast I mean it
was it was yes that's the collective oh
that's how we've felt uh as a crew but I
remember being at the prison because we
had the Warner ready to go over there in
an Australian prison and I was there
rehearsing with you know 50 stunt
performers and I got the call on a
Friday
and you know Patrick Newell our line
producer said we're leaving Australia
and I said should I tell them or do you
want to he's like no you're already
there you go ahead and tell them
and so I did and it was really tough
because you get to say hey the good news
is well let me start with the bad news
we're leaving Australia
but you're all welcome to come with us
because we wanted to honor our
commitment to the to the team long story
short some of them came and we had to go
to Prague
and I think it was kind of a fortuitous
decision because aesthetically for the
film I think it ended up being a happy
accident if you will because the visuals
became much more authentically cold and
kind of the blue aesthetic that you you
know saw up here
to help differentiate the movie from the
first one and so I think it was you know
worked out best for the for the film it
sucked for the you know crew and the
people in Australia it was really tough
and frustrating but for the movie for
the final product I think it actually
worked out pretty good but I think a lot
of people are going to think in this day
and age so much as CGI not much of this
was practical whatever it may be so
for everyone here and for everyone who's
watching the Q a can you talk about the
fact that this was done practically and
what was practical what was CGI and you
know the there was risks involved
especially in the train sequence yes
that was really risky business I mean
you know the it was a Tom Cruise joke
okay good lady in the front row
extra popcorn I think the um
the difficulty nowadays with there's so
many great action movies and I mean I'm
sitting next to you know one of the
great action directors of our era
actually
so there's so many great action movies
the the real question is how do you
differentiate yourself in that Pantheon
that has come before of of great films
and I think all I can do as a filmmaker
is give my specific point of view and
oftentimes these long extended takes in
real locations with real stunts and
practical effects
that's my choice of how I want people to
experience these sequences it doesn't
make them either better than any other
sequence it's just different it's my
point of view than if you gave the
sequence to the Russo Brothers it'd be
freaking amazing but different same you
give it to you know um Macquarie it'd be
different but amazing
and so back to your question sorry for
the long detour
most of what you're seeing in camera is
practical there were times when for
example the Interiors of the train for
the logistics sake
so that we could carry a set like a rain
cover set we we kept those and shot
those on a stage with with blue screen
out uh you know the size of the train
but anything on exterior of the train
including Landing a helicopter on a
moving train was 100 practical
which by its very nature in description
is very dangerous
and so all of those that's something
that we Joe and I have never done as
directors and I don't think we could do
that yeah well thank you I appreciate
that
yeah and you know it was the I think the
hardest part was convincing uh everybody
that that was the way that I wanted to
do it and because you could do it
different ways you could do it 10
different ways you could have it could
be practical you could be outside and
have a big crane swing the helicopter
over and drop it down onto the train and
have big blue screen and it's been done
that way but it in my estimation you
wouldn't provide the audience with the
same adrenaline filled experience
by Faking It
and there's certain times when I think
the risk is worth the reward and in that
instance
we rehearsed
for three or four weeks just that one
part so that all the variables all the
dangerous elements were identified and
then you know we tried to limit the
amount of risk because we all want to go
home at the end of the day to our
friends and loved ones so we're taking
risks but they're calculated risk and
it's all for you for the audience
because I think that adrenaline that
exists in my body as I'm holding the
camera that fear
is translated through to you you know
comes through the screen and you can you
can feel it and your heart beats faster
probably because mine was beating faster
you know we should probably do that
actually hook me up to like a heart rate
monitor and see what my heart rate is
doing that and what yours is
experiencing and I think that'd be very
interesting
thank you
and I want to just um sort of add a
little of my perspective on what Sam is
talking about you know
you to and then many of you may already
know this but you have to understand
Sam's background in his history as a
stunt performer as a stun coordinator as
a action second unit director as a
camera operator as a you know Etc his
entire road to directing there are a few
people on the planet that are as
experienced with
um inventive ambitious action staging
action as as Samus he's what he's done
throughout his career has been very
unique and remarkable and when he he's
able to do things that other people are
not capable of on that level uh because
of his passion and his dedication and
his training and his creativity
um he's he's traveled a very specific
Road through his career to this moment
in time to to what he's been able to
pull off with extraction too so what
he's saying is don't try this at home
train professionals I would say you
don't just pull it out of your ass it's
you know I think you've left out a
little asterisk to the scene which is uh
on that train sequence uh you were the
one holding the camera when the
helicopter landed and what happened to
you well it during the first take
actually when the helicopter came in
I was I knew that you know there is some
wind generated by the downdraft of a
helicopter it stands to reason for them
to fly there has to be force and physics
and yada yada but I didn't realize how
much force and so when I you know ran up
alongside this helicopter I walked into
a hurricane and it blew me sideways and
almost off the side of the train
fortunately again these things that
we're you know taking into consideration
is that might happen and so we had a
safety Line running along the base of
the train hooked to a harness that I was
on which saved my life
I also saved the camera
because that's one for behind the scenes
you want that was the camera cabled or
was it just through your just iron grip
sheer iron grip I think it was fear it
took five minutes to get it released
from my hand
so then I knew that was take one I was
like all right I know what to expect for
take two and you can see if you watch
the if you watch it again and what we
used I believe was take three but you
can see as as the camera goes underneath
the helicopter that it starts to get a
little more wobbly and it's not just my
fear coming through it's the the
downforce of that wind that's just below
I'm trying my best to like operate and
keep them in frame
but it um yeah wild experience I don't I
mean
no I don't recommend it
did you come up with any action
sequences or ideas for an action
sequence that for some reason didn't
work out on this movie and you have it
in the back pocket for the hopeful
extraction three two trains
my big pitch was there should be two
trains it's extraction two
yeah that was the response I got it's
like just stick with one pal just do one
train you know just you're already cut
Nicholas so I'm obsessed with the
editing room because as you both know
that's where a film comes together so
how did this film change in the editing
room after friends and family screenings
and ways you didn't expect well actually
this movie changed from the scripted
form to the you know all that you the
version you guys saw has changed so many
times but I think the biggest change was
the structure the movie originally
opened with the Warner or at least the
script did
and then I think we found you know in a
red amazing is when you read it in Joe's
writing is it's tense and it's
action-packed and you just can't put it
down and next thing you know you're
finished and wanting more
but that doesn't always translate on
screen and what we found was 21 minutes
of action is exciting but if you don't
know who these characters are and what
they're fighting over or for
you're just kind of like okay
let's get to the good stuff
but then when you you know you switch it
and you put 25 minutes of story building
and an emotional connection to these
characters once the action starts now
you can't take your eyes off the screen
because you're emotionally invested in
the journey and you care what happens to
Tyler you care what happens to this
family because you know what the stakes
are so that was something I found very
interesting that we you know we just
changed that in the editing room and it
worked a lot better I mean you guys can
attest to well maybe not but hopefully
attest to being a little more
emotionally involved by the time that
owner rolls around
and I think it's interesting because
you've you know one of those things I'm
sure at some point will rock up on
YouTube and be played just as an action
sequence and I'm sure it'll be fun to
watch but it won't mean nearly as much
as it does to you who've seen the whole
thing
because then there's stakes and I think
that's what makes action sequences so
potentially effective in what I've
learned from working with the Russo
Brothers is action is all about
character and all about emotional Stakes
yeah absolutely
it's interesting through you know along
the the road that we've traveled to in
order to learn this in terms of attack
in a tactile way because you know even
if something seems intuitive I think
when you're an artist and you're
creating something you want to test
ideas you know you you know you don't
want to just accept a premise you want
to you want to figure out why why does
it need to be like this and I you really
want to feel it so I think over the
years like we've played with this idea
of action without like being connected
to emotion or those kinds of things and
it's like you can have the coolest shots
and you can Montage them in the best way
and you can you can have a remarkable
action but if you don't have like a
clear emotional connection to what's
happening within the action
your mind starts to wander after about
30 seconds like that's how quickly it
happens so yeah it's in order in order
to make action really fun for an
audience you have to do exactly what
Sam's saying is just figure out how you
imbue every moment of it with character
and story and stakes and emotional
investment I'm curious what it's like
for you Anthony uh as a producer of the
movie how in how involved are you in
watching every edit and giving notes and
you know what I mean like the behind the
scenes of the agbo of it all
well I mean look agbo was conceived as
an artist Collective and that's really
how we we run it you know we have
amazing uh Partners there like uh Chris
Marcus and Stephen mcfeely and many
other people so part of the virtue of
agbo's process is that we have a lot of
people with putting eyes on all the
material and sort of giving feedback in
terms of what something can be where it
can go but those ideas are offered in a
way that like is useful to the process
you know there's nobody TR you know it's
that's I think how we're different from
from some other places where there may
be less sensitivity to the process and
what something wants to be on a creative
level
um so that's kind of how agbo functions
now every project has a different level
of involvement by the different people
at agbo Joe is much more Hands-On on
this project having written it
um so he's much more tuned in to the
sort of detail evolution of the project
I'm a little more uh sort of one step
back from that
um but yeah it's it's look at it's an
incredibly
important part of the process the
screening part of the process getting
the getting material and fresh eyes
people who might not be as invested in
certain ideas and as locked into how
something was done or why it was done
that way just more open to like how how
is it translating on screen and I think
the one of the most important director
producer relationships that it might
sound counterproductive but is one of
challenging ideas because I might have
an idea as a director and you know the
producer who's got some experience
challenges that not not saying they
disagree they're just challenging say
why do you think that should be in my
movie
and if you can't defend it if you can't
put up a logical reasoning why you want
that you feel passionate about this
being in there then you know it's a
great a backstop for creative ideas
because you know two trains
and just like why two trans and if I
can't defend it in a logical way that's
that makes sense for the story then you
know it falls by the wayside and I think
that's important because if you just get
anything you want anything that comes in
your head you get some you know pretty
messy art so you need to have
collaborators who are willing and brave
enough to challenge you and say hey are
you sure this is the best idea
you know tell me why so I think that's a
great part about agbo is it is kind of
an artist collective in that they
they're the backs up for the the
creative ideas that flow out and the the
best idea wins adage that I learned from
these guys I think that's how they
operate and it really helps the the
product Sam I'm curious uh before you
picture locked I don't know if you'll
remember this before you picture locked
what was the last thing you cut out of
the movie and why
the second train
no that would have been a lot of money
to to leave on the floor if the second
train had made it that far I think it
would have gone the distance all right
we worn that joke out
I I don't remember but I do believe I
know the last thing we got in
to to uh um was the scene with
um Nick walking in with uh and talking
with ketovan about uh Second Chances
that scene with the two women in the
bedroom with the kid lying there
um for a long while it wasn't in there
because it wasn't directly related
um to Tyler rake's story and his journey
but then I fought for that to remain
because indirectly it is talking about
Tyler and his journey because everyone
deserves a second chance
is kind of the information Tyler needs
because you know the guilt he feels and
the shame he feels about his decisions
from the past he doesn't feel like he's
like why am I here I don't deserve a
second chance and so it's kind of
echoing what she said to him in the
opening she being Gall the character of
Nick said you just need to find out why
and I think in her mind is everyone
deserves a second chance and then that
ties into you know Rick going after the
kid because he might have messed up but
maybe he deserves a second chance so
that scene kind of came back because it
supported the Armature of Second Chances
and Redemption but then that was a very
late re-entry to the cut one of the
things I really appreciate about this
movie is uh and what you do is there's
some pretty brutal violence that is that
is
Savage that it's I mean I love it when I
I didn't see this audience but last
night when I saw it with a huge crowd
people were reacting like freaking out
when um I don't want to do spoilers but
when certain people get killed I just
saw the movie oh for your video yeah
okay but like there's like four you know
there's certain things with like a
weight or two there's uh I heard that
stuff like that so how much is that in
the script with Joe saying he gets
killed by a weight and a weight machine
and how much is that you guys in the
moment saying how can we make this just
bloody
well we're all seeking that um fan
appreciation of crazy kills because
again so many amazing action movies so
many great deaths that get recorded it's
hard to stand out and be remembered so a
lot of times what Joe does so well is
he'll write a wild action sequence and
there's some pretty great you know kills
in there and then we as the you know our
eye is the director and then when I hire
the stunt team the collective we try to
take what's there and it's already good
how do we make it better that's always
the goal is like if it's you get a
really good script how do you make it
even really gooder
so in an instant like that when we've
got this gym at our disposal literally a
playground where we say how
what are the Myriad ways we can end
someone's life in this space
and then it's you know getting a bunch
of sick twisted Minds yeah that's you
together which is also the stunt team
and devising lots of different ways and
it becomes a buffet like the you know in
my job a buffet of violence
foreign
counseling sessions afterwards free of
charge
um I'll join you I also need the help
but it's it's a buffet because the with
the adage of the best idea wins I'm not
always the best one to bring that idea
to the table it's not always Joe it's
not always you know Anthony we have good
ideas but the reason filmmaking is so
fun is it's collaborative and so you
have you surround yourself with amazing
artists and then be open to their great
ideas and then as a director my job is
to curate those ideas to pick from the
buffet what you know delicious treat can
we serve up for the audience and how
does it fit into the dish that I'm
trying to prepare as a Master Chef beat
that one to death no more food analogies
yeah but specifically the weights like
there were probably dozens of ideas just
within that space of ways that the stunt
team came up with to in people's
existence and so then I had to go yeah
seen that one or like that's too violent
she'll love it but
and so I get to pick and sometimes
that's the hardest part is picking the
the best ideas from a list of great ones
that's really tough and I think we
landed on two you know our three
exciting versions of that
I just want to mention one thing that
along lines what Sam has been talking
about you know certainly there's a a
creative process that involves you know
not having to explain to other people
what you're doing not having to like
make others understand it just doing
work that ends up becoming something
that people can experience but if you're
gonna ask other creative people to
collaborate with you in order to create
it then in that situation you do have to
communicate your ideas because that's
how that's the essence of collaboration
is your ability to communicate with
whether it be an actor or part of your
stunt team or a producer or maybe even a
financier whoever it might be who's ever
coming to the table to help you make the
collectively make this movie you have to
be able to communicate with one another
about what you're all doing today
together and to piggyback on that just a
fun aside which you guys might eat up
especially you that's three no more
picking on you
my job is to communicate a Feeling
because I might not be the best one to
say how exactly we're going to do it for
example in the the fight in the
courtyard in the prison break
I knew that a feeling I wanted to evoke
and rather than say it has to be in this
karate chop and this you know shot to
the leg whatever that action is
specifically
I pulled up a video on YouTube great
resource
and it was of a lion
fighting off a pack of hyenas
and I played that for the stunt team and
I said this is the feeling I'm going for
it's like Tyler Rick is the lion in case
you were confused
and the hyenas are all the prisoners
around him and it sounds funny but when
you look at it and you look into the
eyes of that lion
there's a desperation there there's a
commitment to survival
and then you watch the kind of attack
methodology of the hyenas and it's very
Savvy they're coming at him from like
all angles and they attack you know
multiple hyenas at a time they go for
the weak points I said I don't really
care how it is we arrive there what
moves you decide to do but I want that
feeling and so then they go off and they
create something they come back and then
I have to go right well that move
doesn't match with what I saw there and
now it becomes a collaboration But
ultimately communicating that feeling to
the people who are going to help you
create moves is my job
I'm curious for both of you this is a
directing question for both of you what
shot or sequence in in maybe it's in
this film or the first extraction or
when you did stunt directing or from
previously and for you with your films
shot or sequence was like the back
breaker the one that like holy F how are
we going to do this well literally uh
not literally but you know what I mean
like a sequence that was like holy F how
are we doing this
I've been talking enough you start
I could talk about so they're all back
Breakers uh making action movies will
break your back yeah and which is which
is where my brain is going uh to the
literal literal version of this answer
which is I remember early on in our
collaboration with Sam
and Captain America Winter Soldier or
this moment where
thank you and if my brain just went to
this moment you can describe it in more
detail but it's like we cap was falling
from a far height he sort of hits this
lands at this dumpster and boom hits the
ground and Sam was going to was
performing this and it was it was such
an intimidating stunt
that I really I didn't I felt like I
couldn't even watch it happen I'm not
kidding you I was so nervous about it
um but Sam did in fact get hurt there
um you want to talk a little bit about
that yeah and I think I mean if we're
talking about the same one it might have
been Civil War the one we can't when it
came out of the roof and hit the truck
was that the one yeah no sorry yeah well
we did a lot of cool stuff together on
both movies
but my memory is burned into mine
um
I was there
so we I remember I was super proud of
this and actually this would we could do
a two for one here because it actually
might make my list of back Breakers but
of most difficult but also kind of most
proud of
um because I remember sitting in the
room and talking about it it was in the
script and it was an explosion goes off
and Captain America flies out of a
window and lands on the pavement and I
was like
that's cool what if and I spoke up in
the room you know we're here it just
kind of brainstorming with the writers
and with Joe and Anthony and I said what
if as he goes out of that window like he
Clips a balcony flips upside down and he
hits a another balcony and then Falls
onto a truck and then he falls down to
the ground and they were like
okay if you can do that it's like not
quite sure let me get back to you but if
I can can we do it and they said yes so
from conception to you know execution I
had to go work with the art department
and like do all the measurements and
build the angle of the you know we had
to build this on the side of a it didn't
exist
where we wanted to shoot so we you know
use the existing balcony built the
second balcony and put park the truck
built you know a padded station for the
the ground to fall on
and then it came to the doing of it and
I shared that stunt actually with
another stunned performer named Jackson
spidell who's an amazing stunt devil he
did the the talent portion
which is he's on a wire rig and he has
to do the flip over the railing which is
takes a lot of skill I did the gravity
portion
which was once that happened it's like
all right Sam you go in there and so I
hung on to the side of a you know a
condor this this uh lift and then it's
three two one let go
and so the night gravity took over and I
fell hit the balcony and then fell 10
feet to the truck 10 feet to the ground
and yeah it took me a while to get back
up after that one now I didn't literally
break my back
not that I remember
it just looked that way but I did I did
um suffer a pretty severe concussion and
um yeah it was I was hobbling around for
a few days a lot of bumps and bruises
but
I remember being very proud of that not
only because I survived
but because the you know Joe and Anthony
allowed me in the room to kind of speak
up and get my Creative Vision on screen
and then I got to go out and help him
build it and then I got to do it so from
reception to completion to be part of
that was really special
I mean I I have to say that I think the
most amazing thing about that story is
that Sam was able to go on and make a
movie like extraction two afterwards I
could still walk away yes and remember
my name we're very close to having to
wrap this but I'm curious for the
audience uh the director here has a
cameo in extraction too did anyone pick
it out
oh I see
no what's the next one
ditch digger bury the bodies yes you are
correct
man I thought I did a better job of
disguising myself and and why did you
choose that role
touche
and the winner is good job
oh that was fantastic
it was therapy it was a bit I think it
was um a bit of a uh you know fortuitous
like I felt like I was digging my own
grave this career choice I'm like what
am I doing so just up doesn't get any
worse than this no that ain't the
truthfully the reason was in the first
film I I had a cameo and doing that it
was only three days of shooting but
those were the hardest three days of my
life
it it gave me a renewed profound respect
for actor directors like a Ben Affleck
or even Joe does that he gets in the
movies and has Parts where you're
speaking and
because there's so much pressure because
you do you go again like as a director I
need another take but as like an actor
like I don't want to be unfair to the
other actor in the scene and like he
only he did it in two and I need his
seventh take
um so it's really tough it's a lot of
pressure and it takes for me twice as
long because you got to perform it and
then go back and watch it you know on
playback and you just feel like I'm
wasting time what am I doing I should
have put someone else in this spot so I
figured what's the worst could happen
I'm digging a ditch
and luckily I didn't hold production up
we did not have to go again for me thank
God did you really try to keep yourself
Anonymous like you thought you weren't
going to get picked out well I mean I I
put like a wig on and I had I colored my
beard and it kinda
on that note I'm just going to say and I
mean this for everybody here
um if you enjoyed the movie please go on
the Facebook and the Instagram and the
Twitter and every other thing and that's
on the internet right yeah it is on your
phone and perhaps spread the word you
know the movie come it's on streaming on
Netflix this Friday uh and on that note
I want to give a huge thank you to
Anthony Russo and Sam Hargrave
thank you all
hope you enjoyed the movie we had a heck
of a fun time making it for you go out
spread the word you're a fun audience
thank you
thank you for coming out